[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i'm arvin kalazici a content
developer and instructor with the
wolfram u team and speaking of wolf from
you today i have here with me jamie
peterson the executive manager of the
wolfram u team hi urban jamie is going
to tell us about
some upcoming moocs our daily study
groups
all of our open courses certification
basically everything will from you
thanks arvin
wolfe from you does occupy a a pretty
substantial part of the wolfram website
and wolf from you is devoted to learning
resources
for all of our users for our user
community and also for computational
topics so when you hit the will from you
website the first thing you'll notice is
a list of subject areas where you can
explore computational ideas and learn
more about fields like machine learning
data science
visualization in addition of course to
helping our users uh learn more about
our technology okay so we have all sorts
of topics here it's not just like
wolfram language related stuff it's how
to do different sorts of things with the
wolfram language exactly computation is
inserted in all kinds of fields and i
think more and more people in maybe not
traditionally computation
fields like the liberal arts and
sciences for instance we have literature
applications where you're pulling data
out of uh out of text and as for one
example and we're finding more and more
people are identifying with this
computational need and so we want to be
an accessible
resource for them for learning how to
use wolfram technology
to achieve that type of goal
yeah so all kinds of resources you
mentioned are interactive courses which
are of course based on our wolfram cloud
they have a series of video lessons and
they're self-paced and in addition to
those video lessons as you learn there's
exercises and auto-graded quizzes and
even exams where you can assess your
knowledge and how your progress through
the course so they're free to everyone
those interactive courses they do
require a will from um id a wolf and
cloud login but those are free yeah
those are free too and the reason for
that is that um you want to track your
progress so if you start a course
finish a section
sign off and come back later you want to
see that you've
accomplished those videos accomplished
those quizzes and hopefully at the end
you earn a certificate of course
completion but in addition to the
courses we have in the video lessons on
our site we have we try to approach
different learning styles and different
needs so we also schedule instructor-led
courses and i think you've actually
taught several of our courses quite a
few right so uh those require advanced
registration and we schedule those on
our calendar and you join fellow
learners online with your instructor and
you work through the course materials
together
of course we offer free webinars
that's been something we've done for
many years and when the new version 13
is released we'll have you can look for
a webinar series on both from you to
learn more about the latest features
there looking forward to that i know bob
talks about this in another tech talk he
talks about the uh paclit repository and
i'm looking forward to getting a bit
more information on that hopefully we
can see that in the webinar absolutely
absolutely
um another major initiative for us in
the last really 17 months during the
pandemic has been daily study groups um
and once again when you're one of the
voices of our daily study group we've
pulled you into those activities they've
been really successful um and we of
course i think forefront in our mind
were students when we started those i
mean you know schools were closing so
many things were being canceled and we
thought we can really um step up and
offer some learning opportunities and so
we ran a calculus study group we ran a
linear algebra study group and they were
so popular and we found that we had not
just students but
professionals
you know adult learners all kinds of
people looking for learning
opportunities to join this cohort of of
others
working towards the same goal becoming
proficient and we've offered study
groups in all kinds of areas um you know
engineering modeling
covered data analysis
and of course uh study groups based on
our own tech so wolfram language basics
and programming tutorials we're part of
the study groups and we've seen people
from kind of all around the world join
these things not just people in every
profession but you know we have people
on several continents joining these
which is great to see yeah and it's hard
you know yet you try to pick a time
because we're all in line together and
it's it's a little bit of a challenge
but we meet monday through friday for an
hour it's 11 a.m start time for us um
u.s central time but you're right we've
had people all over the world so joining
during their evening their morning
whatever and um and taking part in this
community and it's just been really
gratifying to see how meaningful that is
to people to come together be part of
this cohort
work with an instructor online
answer each other's questions even
in the group and
i can give you some stats on some of
those i was just really excited to see
we have over 4 000 individuals
participating in study groups uh since
we started running them in the last year
and um i think over a thousand of them
have pursued some kind of certification
with the study groups okay that's those
are pretty good numbers right i'm a
little biased but i think so and i know
we see a lot of returning users between
all of our study groups i always see
several familiar names uh in our in our
chat and qa pane so while people are
instructing uh of course the students
can ask questions and we have both the
instructor and we have people answering
questions in the in the chat so it's
kind of a nice directed learning
experience it is you mentioned different
learning styles i know some people like
to take things at their own pace go
through a course you know watch some
videos answer some questions and other
people like to have something a little
more directed with an instructor that
they can listen to and ask questions of
you know in real time right so it's
really nice to offer that i think yep
and i think that the certification
numbers are an important indication of
how
valuable that kind of structured
environment can be
not only the certifications earned
through the study group
but like we've had boot camps where
we've brought people in for a very
intense immersive experience and they're
able to go on and get some advanced
certifications
maybe i should explain some more about
that because yeah what sort of boot
camps do we have yeah well we've had um
multi-paradigm data science and neural
networks boot camp both in 2021 they're
both online of course uh but uh plan to
run those again it's uh it's a big
effort to do that so um we'd like to
consider adding some more boot camp
topics i'm not sure how quickly that
will happen but it's something we'd like
to think about
but as far as the certification goes
uh we've had some real progress and
additional
areas of certification offered on
wolfram use so a year ago i was talking
about this new initiative with these
course completions program completions
and then level one certifications which
is a proficiency level and
we have now we have 11 different level
one proficiency certifications offered
through wolfram and uh that's just
that's some tremendous growth for us and
we continue to
continue in that direction but you can
get a level one proficiency in in
calculus by uh working through our
calculus course you can get it in the
wolfram language uh by taking our online
or cloud exam uh in the wolfram language
so it's a it's a variety of different
areas where you can get certified and
and you can look for more to come okay
so these level one certifications you
have to take the course and then there
are quizzes or exams that you have to
take to kind of certify that you've
actually learned the materials right
exactly those level ones have assessment
pieces and most of them well all of them
really are auto graded so we're using
our own wolfram tech to auto grade
exercises problem sets quizzes and uh in
some cases exams and um yeah so those
assessment pieces are important and they
they represent a a certain level of
commitment and work on the part of the
individual to achieve those right and
something that i found really
interesting uh specifically regarding
will from language certifications is
that you know we'll ask coding problems
and people will submit different types
of code you know to solve the same
problem and we have to kind of
you know look at these different types
of code and be able to say okay this is
correct even though these two or three
or four different ways of doing things
are totally different right but they get
the same result and um i am happy to say
at least in in 13 we will be having some
uh improved functionality on that front
so our auto grader will be even better
at that point right i mean it speaks to
the strength of the of the wolfram
language really that there are so many
different ways you can approach a
problem different functionality you can
use um and of course you know everyone
strives to be efficient in their coding
so that's that's a factor but um yeah
it's a real challenge to come up with
that auto grading system uh that's
probably the most significant challenge
we face in offering these certifications
is that um there are so many ways to
achieve results and and we want to be
able to use that auto grading yeah we
don't want to prescribe you know that
you have to do a problem a certain way
so right no that's not what it's about
so yeah that's a good point and um i
guess i could talk about the level two
certification too that's right now we
offer that multi-paradigm data science
but that is not an auto-graded scenario
that's a level two uh project it's uh it
represents applied expertise in a
particular area and that's going to be
individually and personally graded by
one of our certified instructors
like me yeah that's right that's right
so
we hope to add to those uh more advanced
certifications we'd love to see the
certifications posted on people's
linkedin pages on their resumes on their
cvs and their college applications it's
a it's a real way to
distinguish yourself and um and be
acknowledged for the for the level of
proficiency and expertise that you've
achieved
yeah it's really nice to see how many
people again have
gone through the process of getting
certified there
yeah it's it's very rewarding and it's
it's been really
exciting to see the program grow
so you've mentioned that there are some
courses we already have and i know we
have quite a few but i know that we also
have a few coming up in part because i'm
working on one of them yes tell us about
some of the upcoming courses that we
have um right well one of the some of
the newer courses um
visual explorations and data science is
a new interactive course um that i i'm
really fond of because it was uh
it represents kind of you know a very
interesting uh
kind of survey of different data uh
visualizations and case studies but it
was uh put together co-authored and
presented by one of our student interns
and so it's a very um accessible course
and it's a real fresh voice
on wolfe from you so i'm excited to see
visual explorations and data science
offered in our catalog um as you said
you're working on the elementary algebra
course and
that kind of represents the foundational
course right for all these other math
courses but we continue in our math
trajectory as well where we have
calculus linear algebra differential
equations um we'll be coming up very
soon and then multi-variable calculus is
next on the list so we plan to have kind
of a full spectrum of math difficulty
there from algebra
right we keep those math courses coming
um but other there's there's many other
topics um signal processing
neural networks cryptography even these
are all topics we hope to explore in
upcoming interactive courses on the wolf
review website
and of course there's always um shorter
more uh self-paced video lessons coming
online as well
yeah those going pretty frequently yeah
and for the cryptography mooc uh we had
daria on uh for another oh right so
she'll be the one who's working on that
mooc so that's oh she's so passionate
about her her field of study so that's
that's a real joy to see that that
course come together
yeah i'm going to take a look at that
myself because i feel very ignorant
about cryptography right well we all
hear about you know
cryptocurrencies and different concepts
and it's hard to wrap your head around
what all that means so yeah it'll be
it'll be very interesting very timely
topic
all right so there are plenty of new
courses coming up
and some new courses that we've just
released so what's coming up next you
know in the immediate future here right
well um first of all i want to share
with everyone about the next upcoming
study group um that's already open for
registration it starts right after the
tech conference uh introduction to
notebooks will be a two-week study group
it's based on our interactive course by
the same name
and
it'll it'll be just a really
good run through of all topics notebooks
so even those of us who work with
notebooks every day probably there's
always tips to learn and techniques to
make your you know your report
generation a little more efficient
there's a lot of unexplored
functionality there
i've been using notebooks for
oh no
over over a decade and i still see
things sometimes where i'm like oh i
didn't realize that i could do a good
tip and of course we're always adding
new features and functionality um but
immediately following this one will be a
second study group on notebooks it'll be
going further with notebooks and it'll
be a one-week study group really kind of
a deep dive into special topics so
things like tabs and pages and um you
know some of those special things that
maybe you haven't always mastered like
for me
um i you know i love the slideshow mode
so i'm i rely on that all the time but
using tabs and pages is is kind of a
nice feature too and i'm
i'm looking forward to uh the
opportunity to learn a little bit more
about those yeah that sounds good and a
week is a nice compact amount of time to
learn about something some special
topics absolutely so um
that's those study groups are coming up
we also um as i mentioned before have um
new content that we're anxious to get
out there for uh the new user so a
wolfram language basics video course
it'll be a self-paced course um that'll
be coming out very soon on the from you
and um lots of other video lessons um on
notebooks on running in the cloud some
of our basic technologies so that those
uh those people who are who are new to
our technology can get up to speed
quickly okay yeah that's a lot of entry
points that people can choose from
depending on what their specific needs
are right right
well thanks for this opportunity to
share about the wolf from you site it's
uh we spend a lot of day immersed in
this work and uh the the conference is
always a great time to to connect with
people who we've been seeing in study
groups seeing in our courses and our
webinars so it's i appreciate the
opportunity yeah thanks a lot for
letting us know about all these
interesting you know
it's a big it's a big topic from you
right so it's nice to be able to cover
courses daily study groups
certifications upcoming content all this
stuff right so thanks a lot for all of
this information thanks arvin thanks
that was jamie peterson our executive
manager at wolf from u and as you've
just heard we have a lot of new content
coming out new courses new webinars new
study groups and if you do join those
study groups you will see me at those
study groups i will be presenting
answering questions all that stuff so if
you really love these videos for me and
not for the guests please come to the
study groups
stay tuned for more wolfram tech talks
we've got quite a few more coming have a
good one
[Music]